हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल।
तो सबसे पहले आप लोग मुझे यह बता दीजिए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
अगर आप लोगों को मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है तो प्लीज चैट में जल्दी से बता दीजिए।
यस या नो करके ओके
वेरी गुड इवनिंग नोट
एंड बी टोला किड्स। हेलो
नोबक्स
थैंक यू ब्रो एंड
फिन कॉम
हेलो सिस्टर एंड ओके हर हर महादेव
ओके हेलो एवरीवन हेलो एवरीवन तो सबको आई
होप कि मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही होगी तो
गुड चलिए फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं
मैं आपको ले चलते हैं प्रैक्टिकल सेशन
चलो आज का जो हमारा सेशन है वो है
वेपनाइजिंग वीबीए मैक पेलोड।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बेसिकली
अभी तक मैं वीबीए के बारे में बहुत सारी
चीजें पढ़ा चुका हूं। मतलब काफी ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन पढ़ा चुका हूं। ऐसा कुछ भी
नहीं है कि जो मैं आपको फंडामेंटल में
क्लियर नहीं करवाया हो मैंने आपको। तो
फंडामेंटल तो काफी था अब तक। अब आते हैं
हमारे रियल सिनेरियोस पर। अब समय आ गया है
कि इन सारी चीजों को प्रैक्टिकली यूज करने
का एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स एज ए सिक्योरिटी
रिसर्चरर्स दिस इज द राइट टाइम कि हमें
क्या करना है? उस चीज को अडॉप करना है। उस
चीज को यूज़ करना है। तो अब से हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? जितने भी प्रैक्टिकल्स
होने वाले हैं मै डेवलपमेंट के अंदर वो
सारे पेन टेस्टिंग पर्पस या ऑफेंसिव रेड
टीमिंग पर्पस से ही होने वाले हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो जो आज का
टॉपिक है हमारा वेपनाइजिंग वीबीए मैलोड।
अभी आप लोगों को पता होगा वेपनाइजेशन का
मतलब क्या होता है? वेपनाइजेशन का मतलब
क्या होता है? क्योंकि मैं आपको बता चुका
हूं कि रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन
क्या चीजें होती है? तो मैं आपको फिर से
बता देता हूं कि वेपनाइजेशन का मतलब क्या
होता है? वेपनाइजेशन का मतलब होता है कि
आपने इससे पहले के स्टेप में जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की है आपने टारगेट के
बारे में चाहे वो छोटी हो चाहे वो बड़ी हो
उस इंफॉर्मेशन का यूज करना अपने नेक्स्ट
स्टेप के लिए। नेक्स्ट स्टेप क्या है
आपका? इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन करना। और उसके
लिए एक परफेक्ट पेलोड तैयार करना। ठीक है?
उसी का मतलब होता है वेपनाइजेशन। मतलब आप
क्या कर रहे हो? आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन को एक
वेपन के रूप में एक हथियार के तौर पर यूज
करने वाले हो आप उस टारगेट सिस्टम पर
इनिशियल एक्सेस लेने के लिए। ओके? इनिशियल
एक्सेस लेने के लिए। तो चलिए तो आज का जो
फर्स्ट प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन स्टार्ट
करने जा रहे हैं वो है हमारा सिस्टम
एनुमरेशन एंड एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन। ठीक है?
सिस्टम एनुमरेशन एंड एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन।
बेसिकली वो हमारा प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो
रहेगा। ये प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो आज के
क्लास में कंप्लीट नहीं होगा क्योंकि मुझे
स्टेप बाय स्टेप आपको बताना है हर एक चीज
को कि हम कैसे करने वाले हैं। दैट्स व्हाई
ये आज का जो सिनेरियो है ये दो क्लासेस
में कवर होगा। तो नेक्स्ट तो प्रैक्टिकल
सिनेरियो में क्या है आपका? प्रैक्टिकल
सिनेरियो यह है कि एज ए आप क्या है? एक
अटैकर हो एक पेंटेस्टस हो। आप क्या यूज़ कर
रहे हो? कालीनेस का यूज़ कर रहे हो। आपने
क्या किया? सबसे पहले स्टेप वन में आपने
एक मिलिशियस Microsoft Word फाइल को क्या
किया? डेवलप किया। डेवलप करने के बाद आपने
किसी भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक के
द्वारा अपने टारगेट मशीन के पास भेज दिया।
सेकंड स्टेप में आपने क्या किया कि कोई भी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक का यूज किया,
चाहे ईमेल का यूज किया। कैसे भी आपने अपने
टारगेट सिस्टम के पास भेज दिया। आपके
टारगेट मशीन के पास भेज दिया। और आपको
इतना पता था कि आपकी टारगेट मशीन क्या है?
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का यूज कर रही
है। और जैसे ही आपने आपके टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पे भेजा या टारगेट मशीन पर या
टारगेट सिस्टम के पास उस फाइल को भेजा तो
जैसे ही जो यूजर था यूजर ने उस पे डबल
क्लिक किया। डबल क्लिक करते ही वो फाइल
ओपन हो गई। कौन? क्योंकि माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
वर्ड फाइल थी और फाइल ओपन होते ही उसके
अंदर आया एक इनेबल कंटेंट करके ऊपर छोटा
सा एक बटन और अटैकर ने उस इनेबल कंटेंट
बटन पे भी क्या कर दिया? क्लिक कर दिया।
और जैसे ही अटैकर ने क्या किया? उस बटन पे
क्लिक किया। क्लिक करते ही इसमें क्या था?
मिलसियस पेलोड था। इसके अंदर मिलसियस
पेलोड थे। उसने क्या किया? इंफॉर्मेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग करना स्टार्ट कर दिया। सबसे
पहले इनेबल कंटेंट करते ही इंफॉर्मेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग परफॉर्म की। मतलब सिस्टम जो
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन की रिक्वायरमेंट थी वो
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या की उसने कलेक्ट की और उस
इंफॉर्मेशन को कलेक्ट करके नेक्स्ट स्टेप
में क्या किया? आपका जो अटैकर मशीन थी जो
आपकी लinक्स मशीन थी उसके पास भेज दिया।
ये है आपका पूरा सिनेरियो जो हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? स्टेप बाय स्टेप इस सिनेरियो को
कवर करने वाले हैं। ठीक है? स्टेप वन में
हम क्या करेंगे? मिलीसियस पेलोड को डेवलप
भी करेंगे। स्टेप टू को स्किप करेंगे। हम
अस्यूम करेंगे कि आपने टारगेट मशीन के पास
भेज दिया। टारगेट पे उसको क्या करेगा? डबल
क्लिक भी करेगा। इनेबल कंटेंट पे भी क्लिक
करेगा। उसके बाद प्रैक्टिकली
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हार्वेस्टिंग होगी। और
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हार्वेस्टिंग होने के बाद
आपके जो लinक्स मशीन है उसके ऊपर भी क्या
होगा? वो कनेक्शन के द्वारा वो फाइल
ट्रांसफर कर दी जाएगी। तो यह पूरा हमारा
आज का और अगली क्लास का प्रैक्टिकल
सिनेरियो है जो हम पूरा प्रैक्टिकली
परफॉर्म करेंगे स्टेप बाय स्टेप बिल्कुल
प्रैक्टिकली अंडरस्टुड सिनेरियो आई होप कि
सबको समझ में आ गया होगा कि हमारा
प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो क्या है
सबको क्लियर है प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो हम
क्या डिस्कस करने वाले हैं यह पूरा
प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो रहेगा स्टेप 1 3 4 5
तो अभी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सबसे
पहला स्टेप वन मेरा एक सवाल है। स्टेप वन
यह है कि हाउ टू क्रिएट ए मशियस Microsoft
Word डॉक्यूमेंट? तो सबसे पहला सवाल मेरा
आप लोगों से यह है कि हम ये Microsoft जो
मशियस Microsoft Word डॉक्यूमेंट की बात
कर रहे हैं। वो कैसे क्रिएट करेंगे?
किसी को कोई आईडिया है कि जो Microsoft
Word डॉक्यूमेंट है उसको हम मशियस
Microsoft Word डॉक्यूमेंट में कैसे बना
सकते हैं? स्टेप वन कैसे परफॉर्म करेंगे?
डू यू हैव एनी आईडिया?
किसी को कोई भी आईडिया है? वेरी गुड।
बिल्कुल एनोनिमस वीबीए का भी यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। दूसरा जिसने भेजा 2482 एमएसएफ वनम।
बट एमएसएफ वनम वाला भी पेलोड इंसर्ट करने
के लिए हमें किसको यूज़ करना पड़ेगा? वीबीए
को यूज़ करना पड़ेगा। तो उसके ऊपर भी हमारा
अपकमिंग क्लास में सिनेरियो है। तो
बिल्कुल हमें यूज़ करेंगे मैक का। तो स्टेप
वन का तो क्लियर है कि हमें अगर किसी
मलेशियस फाइल को डेवलप करना है तो हमें
क्या करना पड़ेगा?
हमें मैक मशियस मैक कोड या मशियस मैक
पेलोड डेवलप करना पड़ेगा। अगला जैसा कि
मैंने आपको बोला स्टेप टू हम नहीं करने
वाले क्योंकि स्टेप टू आपको रिसर्च करना
आप कैसे कर सकते हो। स्टेप टू को हम
अस्यूम कर रहे हैं कि आपने क्या किया कि
उस मिलसियस पेलोड को किसके पास भेज दिया?
टारगेट के पास। तो आ गया आपका स्टेप थ्री
कि स्टेप थ्री में क्या है? आपका क्या
रहेगा? द यूजर शुड डबल क्लिक द डॉक्यूमेंट
एंड इनेबल कंटेंट। मतलब क्या है कि मैं आप
लोगों से एक सवाल पूछता हूं कि
पहला सवाल यह है कि हम उस डॉक्यूमेंट का
टाइटल या उस डॉक्यूमेंट का टाइटल ऐसा क्या
रखने वाले हैं या जो डॉक्यूमेंट है उसके
टाइटल टाइटल में ऐसा क्या होगा कि यूजर उस
पे डबल क्लिक करे।
डॉक्यूमेंट का टाइटल ऐसा क्या होगा कि
यूजर ने उसे देखते ही डबल क्लिक कर दिया।
ठीक है? पहला सवाल। दूसरा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सवाल यह है।
ठीक है? टाइटल देख के यूजर ने डबल डबल
क्लिक कर दिया। लेकिन फिर इनेबल कंटेंट पर
भी क्लिक कर दिया।
सोचने की बात है ना कि आप एक मिलिशियस
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट बना रहे हो
जिसमें
आपको क्या करवाना है? यूजर से दो काम
करवाने हैं। एक तो डबल क्लिक करवाना है।
दूसरा इनेबल कंटेंट पर क्लिक करवाना है।
तो आप ऐसा क्या टाइटल बनाओगे जिससे यूजर
उस पर डबल क्लिक करे। दूसरा उसके अंदर
इनेबल कंटेंट करे।
तो यह चीजें आपकी डिपेंड करती हैं आपके
पूरे स्प्रे टेक्स्ट के ऊपर। आपकी
इंफॉर्मेशन के ऊपर इससे पहले वेपनाइजेशन
से पहले आपने जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की
है जो भी आपने प्लानिंग की है इनिशियल
एक्सेस गेन करने के लिए या जो भी आप
सिनेरियो सोच रहे हो यह टोटली उस पे
डिपेंड करता है कि आप टाइटल क्या रखोगे।
दूसरा जो सवाल था कि ठीक है डबल क्लिक के
लिए टाइटल तो आपने सोच लिया तो इनेबल
कंटेंट पर भी क्यों क्लिक करेगा यह भी
आपका उस प्रीटेक्स्ट के ऊपर ही डिपेंड
करता है कि एक यूजर या आपका जो टारगेट
यूजर है या टारगेट एंप्लई है या चाहे
मैनेजर हो चाहे कोई भी हो वो उस पे इनेबल
कंटेंट क्यों करेगा ये दोनों ही सिनेरियो
या दोनों ही सवाल है ये क्या करेंगे आपके
डिपेंड करते हैं आपके सिनेरियो पर आपके
प्रिटेक्स्ट पर आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन पर कि आप
ने जो इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की है उस
इंफॉर्मेशन के बेसिस पर आप नेक्स्ट
सिनेरियो क्या डेवलप करने वाले हैं? तो ये
दोनों को दोनों चीजें क्या है? आपकी
डिपेंड करती है किसके ऊपर? आपके प्रिटेक्स
के ऊपर। इसका जवाब आपको मिल गया होगा। अभी
आते हैं स्टेप फोर पर। ठीक है? स्टेप फोर
पर।
ठीक है? जो स्टेप फोर क्या होगा आपका?
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग। ठीक है? अब
स्टेप फोर जो हम डेवलप करेंगे, हमने क्या
किया? डिस्कस किया कि टाइटल भी हमने इतना
शानदार लिया कि यूजर ने उस पर डबल क्लिक
कर दिया और उसके अंदर भी कंटेंट इतना
शानदार लिखा कि यूजर ने इनेबल कंटेंट भी
कर दिया। बात आती है कि जब आपने
यूजर ने डबल क्लिक भी कर दिया। इनेबल
कंटेंट पर भी क्लिक कर दिया। उसके बाद हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग। हमें इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को क्या
करना है? एक्स फिल्ट्रेट करना है। ठीक है?
अब वो इंफॉर्मेशन हमें क्या-क्या चाहिए?
जैसे कि हमारे जो सिनेरियो है हमें
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशनेशन,
नेटवर्क की डिटेल चाहिए हमें। इंस्टॉल्ड
सॉफ्टवेयर्स की डिटेल चाहिए, यूजर्स या
ग्रुप्स की इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए एटसेट्रा एंड
एसेट्रा। ये आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट पे डिपेंड
करता है कि आपको कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए।
तो जैसे ही इनेबल कंटेंट हुआ आपकी क्या
होगा? इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग होगी। ये
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे कि हम यूज करने वाले
हैं सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन नेटवर्क डिटेल
इंस्टेंस सॉफ्टवेयर डिटेल्स यूजर्स ग्रुप
इंफॉर्मेशन एट्रा ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
करेंगे हम कलेक्ट करेंगे और सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन को कलेक्ट करके चुपचाप करेंगे
ठीक है हम क्या करेंगे कलेक्ट करके जो
सारी हार्वेस्टेड इनेशन है इसको हम क्या
करेंगे उसी टारगेट मशीन उसी हमारी विंडो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम उसी के टेम फोल्डर टेम
क्या है आपका एक टेंपरेरी फोल्डर होता है
उसके अंदर क्या कर देंगे? स्टोर कर देंगे।
अंडरस्टुड? यूजर ने डबल क्लिक किया। डबल
क्लिक करके बाद इनेबल कंटेंट किया। उसके
बाद आपका पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट होता है। पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूट होने के बाद इंफॉर्मेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग परफॉर्म होती है। जो
इंफॉर्मेशन आपने कलेक्ट की उस कलेक्टेड
इंफॉर्मेशन को या जो हार्वेस्टेड
इंफॉर्मेशन को आपने विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर उसके एक टेंपरेरी फोल्डर्स
है। उसके अंदर सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्ट के नाम
से क्या कर दिया? सेव कर दिया। सिस्टम
ऑडिट रिपोर्ट के नाम से सेव कर दिया।
स्टेप फोर में। अंडरस्टुड गाइस?
अंडरस्टुड गाइस?
स्टेप वन, स्टेप थ्री, स्टेप फोर क्लियर
है कि हम क्या-क्या करने वाले हैं। ये
सारे स्टेप प्रैक्टिकली परफॉर्म होने वाले
हैं। इनमें से ऐसा कोई भी स्टेप नहीं है
जो प्रैक्टिकली परफॉर्म नहीं होने वाला।
ओके? तो, उसके बाद आता है आपका, ठीक है,
सर।
टाइटल भी चूज कर लिया, डबल क्लिक भी करवा
लिया, इनेबल कंटेंट भी करवा लिया,
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग भी कर ली और उसको
एक फाइल में भी स्टोर कर लिया। यहां तक
हमने उसको एक फाइल में भी स्टोर कर लिया।
यहां तक सब कुछ कर लिया। तो नेक्स्ट स्टेप
आता है आपका एक्स फिल्ट्रेटिंग दिस
हार्वेस्टेड डेटा टू द अटैकर मशीन। उसके
बाद हमें क्या करना है? जो डेटा हमने क्या
किया था? हार्वेस्ट किया था, कलेक्ट किया
था, एक फाइल के अंदर स्टोर किया था। किसके
अंदर? सिस्टम ऑडिट डॉट रिपोर्ट के अंदर
टेंपरेरी फोल्डर के अंदर उसको क्या करना
है हमें किसके पास भेजना है अटैकर मशीन के
पास भेजना है ठीक है उस हार्वेस्टेड
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को एक्स फिल्ट्रेट करना है
क्या करना है उसको एक्स फिल्ट्रेट करना है
तो उसके पॉसिबल ट्रांसमिशन मेथड क्या हो
सकते हैं बहुत सारे हो सकते हैं ठीक है तो
हमें क्या करना है हम सबसे पहले क्या
करेंगे हम सबसे पहले हमारी स्क्रिप्ट में
ठीक है जो फाइल है सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt
इस फाइल को रीड करेंगे। सबसे पहले इस फाइल
के डेटा को रीड करेंगे। डेटा को रीड करने
के बाद हम क्या करेंगे? जो अटैकर मशीन है
स्टेप टू में इसी में भी स्टेप फाइव के
अंदर पहला काम क्या करेंगे? हम जो सिस्टम
ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt फाइल है, इसको रीड करेंगे।
इसके डेटा को रीड करके कहीं पर स्टोर
करेंगे। स्टोर करके जो आपकी अटैकर मशीन
है, आपकी जो काली लinक्स की मशीन है, उसके
साथ क्या करेंगे? कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
करेंगे। ठीक है? इस मशीन से आपके टारगेट
मशीन से आपकी अटैकर मशीन पर एक कनेक्शन
इस्टैब्लिश करेंगे। कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
करने के बाद जो आपने फाइल से डेटा रीड
किया था उस डेटा को आपकी जो अटैकर मशीन है
उसके पास भेज देंगे। और जब आपने एक बार उस
डेटा को मशीन के ऊपर भेज दिया। सेम टाइम
कनेक्शन को क्लोज करेंगे और इस फाइल को
डिलीट कर देंगे ताकि
हम पकड़ में ना आए। इस फाइल को हम डिलीट
भी कर देंगे। सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt यह
सारे काम करने वाले हैं स्टेप फाइव में।
स्टेप फाइव क्या है? हमारा सबसे क्रूशियल
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है जो हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में करेंगे। वो आज की क्लास के लिए
तो बिल्कुल भी नहीं है। बिकॉज़ इसमें मुझे
एक्सप्लेन करना है कि स्टेप बाय स्टेप
कैसे चीजें हमने परफॉर्म की। बट इसमें चार
चीजें होंगी। चार काम होंगे। स्टेप फाइव
में पहले डेटा को रीड करना है। उसके बाद
कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश करना है। फिर उसके बाद
उस डेटा को टैकर मशीन पे भेजना है। डेटा
भेजने के बाद कनेक्शन को क्लोज करना है।
उस फाइल को डिलीट करना है।
स्टेप फाइव क्लियर है गाइस?
यहां तक स्टेप फाइव आपको क्लियर है।
अगर आपको स्टेप फाइव क्लियर है तो हम आगे
बढ़ते हैं।
क्लियर है यहां तक?
गुड।
चलो जी डोंट वरी नोट्स की चिंता मत कीजिए।
पीपीटीज आपको हमारे टेलीग्राम ग्रुप में
मिल जाएंगे। जो क्लास नोट्स के नाम से
टेलीग्राम ग्रुप बनाया हुआ है। उसमें आपको
ये सारे नोट्स पीपीटीज आपको मिल जाएंगी।
उसको प्रोवाइड कर दी जाएगी। वहां पर आप
अपने डाउट्स भी डिस्कस कर सकते हो। वो
उसके लिए मैंने एक डाउट
के लिए अलग से एक जगह प्रोवाइड की है उसी
ग्रुप के अंदर जहां पर आप क्या कर सकते
हो? अपने डाउट भी पूछ सकते हो रिलेटेड टू
द एनी क्लास या कोई भी आप अपना डाउट वहां
से पूछ सकते हो फ्यूचर्स के रिगार्डिंग।
ओके? तो देखो अभी भी मैसेज आ रहे हैं जो
लोग ज्वाइन कर रहे हैं और जो टेलीग्राम का
जो लिंक है ये आपको कहां देखने को मिलेगा
ये मिलेगा जो हमारी क्लास चल रही है
प्रेजेंट क्लास चल रही है इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में देखने को मिलेगा क्लास
नोट्स के नाम से वहां पर एक लिंक होगा
वहां पर क्लिक कीजिए ज्वाइन ग्रुप को आप
ज्वाइन कर सकते हो और आपको सारे नोट्स
वहीं पर मिल जाएंगे क्योंकि वहां पर
ऑलरेडी 50 टू 60 स्टूडेंट्स हैं अभी और आई
होप कि मैं उम्मीद करता हूं कि ये इतनी
बड़ी स्ट्रेंथ बने इतना बड़ा ग्रुप बने कि
जिसमें आपको अपने फ्यूचर्स में हर एक चीज
मिले। अगर जो मैं नोट्स आपको प्रोवाइड कर
सकता हूं वो प्रोवाइड करो। जो रेफरेंसेस
मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर सकता हूं। आई विल
ट्राई माय बेस्ट। आपकी हेल्प करने की
कोशिश करो। चलिए हम टॉपिक पे आते हैं।
नेक्स्ट अभी सर आपने तो बताया। ठीक है। सर
स्टेप थ्री में आप क्या करने वाले हो? आप
ऐसा टाइटल में क्या रखने वाले हो? या आप
ऐसा क्या टेक्स्ट ऐसा क्या सिनेरियो लेकर
आने वाले हो कि जिससे एक यूजर उस पर डबल
क्लिक करे या फिर इनेबल कंटेंट करें।
इनेबल कंटेंट पर क्लिक करे। उसका
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन की हम तैयारी
करते हैं। ठीक है? उसके लिए हम क्या
करेंगे? लेर टेंपलेट डिजाइन करेंगे। तो
मेरा सिनेरियो क्या है? मेरा सिनेरियो है
कि इमेजिन योर टारगेट इज ए पीजी वॉइस
प्रेसिडेंट ऑफ ह्यूमन रिसोर्सेज और ए
सीनियर टेक्निकल रिक्रूटर एट ग्लोबल बैंक
कॉरपोरेशन एट ग्लोबल बैंक कॉरपोरेशन मतलब
हमारा टारगेट क्या है एक वॉइस प्रेसिडेंट
ऑफ एचआर टीम या फिर एक सीनियर टेक्निकल
रिक्रूटर है किसके अंदर ग्लोबल बैंक
कॉरपोरेशन के अंदर जो क्या करता है ग्लोबल
बैंक कॉरपोरेशन में काम करता है इस बैंक
बैंक के अंदर वो एक सीनियर टेक्निकल
रिक्रूटर या एक वॉइस बीपी है। किसका? एचआर
डिपार्टमेंट का। नाउ ग्लोबल बैंक इज
करेंटली रनिंग ए हाई प्रोफाइल
कॉन्फिडेंशियल हायरिंग ड्राइव फॉर ए लीड
एंटप्राइज क्लाउड आर्किटेक्ट ए क्रिटिकल
लीडरशिप ब्रो। बेसिकली क्या है कि जो
ग्लोबल बैंक में अभी क्या हो रहा है जो
मेरे सिनेरियो के अकॉर्डिंग कि एक हायरिंग
चल रही है बहुत बड़ी किसके लिए लीड
एंटरप्राइज क्लाउड आर्किटेक्ट के लिए इसकी
जो पोजीशंस है इसके लिए बहुत बड़े लेवल पर
हायरिंग चल रही है क्योंकि और ये जो लेवल
है जिसकी जो हायरिंग चल रही है ये काफी
हाई लेवल है लीडरशिप रोल के लिए ये जो
लेवल है ये हाई लेवल है आपके लीडरशिप रोल
के लिए ओके बिकॉज़ दिस दिस पोजीशन हैंडल्स
कोर बैंकिंग सिक्योरिटी एंड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। अभी जो ये पोजीशंस है ये
क्या किस चीज को हैंडल करती है? जो
बैंकिंग इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है किसके अंदर?
ग्लोबल बैंक कॉरपोरेशन के अंदर उसकी जो
सिक्योरिटी है या इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है उसको
क्या करती है? हैंडल करती है। उसको क्या
करती है? हैंडल करती है और इस तरह की जो
जो एचआर डिपार्टमेंट्स है डेली बेसिस पर
इस जो रिक्रूटमेंट चल रही है जिसकी जो
हायरिंग चल रही है इस हायरिंग से रिलेटेड
दर्जन सैकड़ों क्या करते हैं रिज्यूे उनको
डेली बेसिस पर मिलते हैं ठीक है तो
बेसिकली आपको समझ में आ गया हम क्या करने
वाले हैं हम बनाने वाले हैं एक रिज्यूे हम
बनाने वाले हैं एक प्रोफेशनल रिज्यूुमे जो
क्या करने वाले हैं हम फॉर एग्जांपल हम
अस्यूम कर रहे हैं कि हमने एक रिज्यूुमे
बनाया आया बिल्कुल एग्जजेक्टली एक वैलिड
रिज्यूमे है और जिसको हम अस्यूम करें कि
हमने एचआर डिपार्टमेंट में भेजा और जिसे
देखकर क्या करेगा आपके जो हायरिंग टीम है
उस पे क्लिक करेगी व्हेन द रिक्रूटर ओपन
देयर इनफो इनबॉक्स फर्स्ट थिंग इन द
मॉर्निंग दे सी ए रिज्यूमे फॉर एन एलाइड
कैंडिडेट कंप्लीट विद ए सीआईएसएफ
सर्टिफिकेशन बेसिकली जैसे ही रिक्रूटर को
वो ईमेल मिलती है और सुबह मॉर्निंग में
सुबह जब जैसे अपने ईमेल बॉक्स को ओपन करता
है। उसको एक ईमेल मिलती है। उसको देखता है
कि एक कैंडिडेट कैंडिडेट का रिज्यूे आया
है। जिसने सीआईएसएफ सर्टिफिकेशन कंप्लीट
कर रखा है। और उसके पास टॉप टियर बैंकिंग
या उसको बहुत सारे बड़े-बड़े बैंकों में
काम करने का एक्सपीरियंस भी है। और जैसे
ही उस रिज्यूुमे को देखा उसने डबल क्लिक
कर दिया। जैसे ही इस टाइप के रिज्यूुमे को
देखा उन्होंने क्या कर दिया? डबल क्लिक कर
दिया। ये है हमारा सिनेरियो। अब यहां पर
ट्रैप कहां पर है? बोला सर यह तो आपका
सिनेरियो। आपने मान लिया कि एक हायरिंग चल
रही है। हायरिंग में हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? एक रिज्यूुमे बनाने वाले हैं। तो
हमारा ट्रैप क्या है? हमारा ट्रैप है
इंस्टेड ऑफ सीइंग द रिज्यूे इमीडिएटली
वर्ड ओपन्स टू ए क्लीन प्रोफेशनल
कॉर्पोरेट नोटिस वार्निंग दैट द
डॉक्यूमेंट इज प्रोटेक्टेड बाय एएस 256
डीआरएम एंड रिक्वायर्ड हार्डवेयर टोकन
वैलिडेशन।
जैसे ही
उस रिक्रूटर ने उस पर डबल क्लिक किया, डबल
क्लिक करते ही रिज्यूे में क्या हुआ? एक
प्रोफेशनल कॉर्पोरेट नोटिस आएगा। ठीक है?
एक वार्निंग आएगी। ठीक है? मतलब डायरेक्ट
जो रिज्यूे था कैंडिडेट का वो नहीं ओपन
हुआ। एक वार्निंग आएगी जिसमें लिखा हुआ है
कि ये डॉक्यूमेंट है एएस 256 डीआरएम से
प्रोटेक्टेड है। ठीक है? और इसको ओपन करने
के लिए हार्डवेयर टोकन वैलिडेशन की
रिक्वायरमेंट है। ठीक है? अभी ये तो लिख
दिया। साथ में एक और लाइन लिखी टू बायपास
द ब्लैंक स्पेस या अप्रेंटिक। अभी ये जो
इंग्लिश लिखी है शायद आपको समझ में ना आए।
तो मैं सीधा-सीधा बोल देता हूं कि उसमें
साथ के साथ यह भी लिखा था कि अगर आपको इस
डॉक्यूमेंट को डिक्रिप्ट करना है तो ऊपर
एक येलो कलर के लाइन आएगी जिसमें क्या है?
इनेबल एडिटिंग या इनेबल कंटेंट लिखा हुआ
है। आप उस पे क्लिक कर दीजिए और आपका जो
डॉक्यूमेंट है वो डिक्रिप्ट हो जाएगा।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? रिज्यूुमे में ये लिखा
एक वार्निंग हमने प्रोवाइड की कि भैया ये
प्रोटेक्टेड डॉक्यूमेंट है। जैसे आप ऊपर
एक येलो लाइन आ रही है। उसमें एक बटन है।
इनेबल कंटेंट पे क्लिक करोगे तो ये
डॉक्यूमेंट आपका प्रोटेक्टेड हो जाएगा। या
सॉरी डिक्रिप्ट हो जाएगा। आपका डॉक्यूमेंट
क्या हो जाएगा? डिक्रिप्ट हो जाएगा। और
यहीं तक नहीं है हमने इसको पूरे सिनेरियो
को हमने पूरा कवर किया है कि सिर्फ हमने
यहां पर पॉप अप ही नहीं दिया हमने ये भी
सिनेरियो क्रिएट करेंगे कि जैसे ही सच में
यूज़ उस पर इनेबल कंटेंट करेगा तो क्या
होगा कि जो वार्निंग बॉक्स था वो छिप
जाएगा और उसके बाद जो रिज्यूे है एक्चुअल
में रिज्यूे है वो क्या हो जाएगा वो दिख
जाएगा क्योंकि जो पहले बैकग्राउंड में
हमने छुपा रखा था तो बेसिकली बात ये है कि
जो भी कुछ हम करने वाले हैं। जो कुछ हम
डिजाइन करने वाले हैं वो सच में बहुत ही
ज्यादा प्रैक्टिकली है। कुछ भी उसमें ऐसा
नहीं है कि जो प्रैक्टिकली ना हो। ठीक है?
तो चलो फिर हम स्टेप बाय स्टेप पहले इसको
क्या करते हैं जो हमारी टेंपलेट है इसको
डिजाइन करते हैं कि सर कि ऐसा मतलब
परफेक्ट बिल्कुल उसी को हम टेंपलेट को
डिजाइन करते हैं। उसके बाद हम क्या
करेंगे? अपना मशियस पे डिजाइन करेंगे।
सिनेरियो सबको क्लियर हो गया?
ठीक है। चलो फिर प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
करते हैं। हम आपको भी पता चल जाएगा।
हम चलते हैं Microsoft पर। MS Word को हम
ओपन करते हैं। ठीक है? हम MS Word को ओपन
करने वाले हैं और बिल्कुल सरियो डिजाइन
करने वाला। हमने क्या किया? ब्लैंक
डॉक्यूमेंट। तो इसको मैं क्या कर देता
हूं? क्लोज कर देता हूं। और मैंने उसके
लिए एक और चीज की है। मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं? हां मैंने लिखा हुआ है। तो ब्लैंक
डॉक्यूमेंट तो आपने ओपन कर लिया। तो आपको
यहां पर क्या करना है? अभी सबसे पहले टॉप
हेडर होता है। हेडर में जाना है आपको। और
हेडर में हम क्या लिखने वाले हैं? सबसे
पहले हेडर है। और हेडर में हम लिखने वाले
हैं। चलिए फिर क्या लिखते हैं हम? सबसे
पहले ये रहा।
ग्लोबल बैंक।
ग्लोबल
ग्लोबल बैंक कॉरपोरेशन केओआरपी
उसके बाद ये रहा
उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले हैं? ये रहा
लिखते हैं
टैलेंट एक्विजेशन पोर्टल
ए सी क यू आई
एस एक्विजिशन पोर्टल
थोड़ा स्पेलेल मिस्टेक है ये इसी के लिए
बाकी मैं कट कॉपी पेस्ट ही करने वाला हूं
तो इसको हम क्या करते हैं चलिए फिर हम
प्लान करते हैं सबको आता होगा मैं मान के
चल रहा हूं इसमें कुछ बताने वाली बात नहीं
इसको सेंटर में करते सेंटर में करने के
बाद इसको हम बोल्ड करते हैं। बोल्ड करने
के बाद इसको हम क्या करते हैं? नॉर्मली
एरियल यूज़ यूज की जाती है इंडस्ट्री में।
इसको हम 10 पे रखते हैं। इसका 11 या तो हम
10 सही रहेगा। परफेक्ट है। और बिल्कुल
प्रोफेशनल बनाने के लिए। और बोल्ड कर
दिया। देन इसका हम जो कलर है कलर भी सेट
करेंगे। कलर रखते हैं हम इसका। कुछ ब्लू
लाइट ब्लू बिल्कुल नहीं। हम रखने वाले हैं
डार्क ब्लू। डार्क ब्लू रखते हैं। इस
तरीके से डार्क ब्लू रख लिया हमने या फिर
ग्रे रखते हैं। ग्रे इज द परफेक्ट वन। एंड
दिस इज द डार्क ग्रे। दिस इज़ द डार्क
ग्रे। नो नो ये ब्लैक है। ये परफेक्ट वन।
ये सही रहेगा हमारा।
ये हो गया। ठीक है? हमने हेडर बना लिया।
परफेक्ट है हमारे पास। और पॉइंट नंबर 10।
ठीक है? अब डबल क्लिक करके हम बाहर आ जाते
हैं। तो ये हमारा सेंटर में रहेगा हेडर।
उसके बाद हमने क्या किया? उसके बाद हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? नेक्स्ट गो टू इंसर्ट
टैब। एक टेबल बनाते हैं वन बाय वन की।
हमने टेबल को बना लिया। ठीक है? अब टेबल
को बना लिया। इसमें कंटेंट मेरा क्या
रहेगा? मैं कंटेंट पे चलता हूं। भैया आ
जाओ। ये रहा। तो यहां से उठाता हूं मैं।
ये रहा। ये मेरा पूरा कंटेंट है। ग्लोबल
एंटरप्राइज ये एक्सचेंज रिक्वायर्ड। ये
रहा ये रहा। जिसको मैं क्या करने वाला
हूं? इसके अंदर रखने वाला हूं। तो
परफेक्टली फाइन। चलो। तो इसके अंदर मैं ये
पेस्ट कर दे रहा हूं। ये मैंने पेस्ट कर
दिया। तो इसको थोड़ा सा हम हाईलाइट करते
हैं। थोड़ा सा एडिटिंग करते हैं इसकी। ठीक
है? तो एडिटिंग कर लेते हैं। पहले ये रहा
पहले इसको हम पूरे को इसको रखते हैं। सेम
एरियल
इंसर्ट बाद में इसको पहले एक काम करते
हैं। डिजाइनिंग कर लेते हैं इसके टेबल की।
टेबल की डिजाइनिंग भी कर लेंगे। वेट एंड
ये रहा। इसका हम रखते हैं राउंड। सेम सही
है। परफेक्टली इसको रख लेते हैं 12। और
इसको हम फिर से रियल रख लेते हैं। नाउ
इट्स वेरी गुड नाउ। चलो इसको हम क्या करते
हैं? परफेक्ट।
डोंट वरी। देखो बिल्कुल प्रोफेशनल बनाएंगे
हम। एंड यह रहा
कॉन्फिडेंशियल
पॉलिसी
एंड टारगेट इक्वेशन
प्रोफेशनल देखते जाइए कोई
यह
एंड ये रहा। इसको भी हम क्या कर देते हैं?
बोल्ड कर देते हैं। और इसको हम करते हैं
थोड़ा क्योंकि वार्निंग टाइप की है तो इसको
हम थोड़ा रेड रखते हैं। तो ज्यादा रेड नहीं
करेंगे। इसको हम परफेक्ट रहेगा। एक्शन
रिक्वायर्ड ये सो परफेक्ट। दिस फाइल इज़
इंक्रिप्टेड विद AS 256 बिट DRM। इसको हाई
मोटे कर हाईलाइट कर देते हैं थोड़ा सा। एंड
यह रहा microsoft वर्ड हैस ब्लॉक डायनेमिक
मैस रिक्वायर्ड टू वैलिडेट योर हार्डवेयर
के टोकन टू कंप्लीट आइडेंटिटी हैंडशक एंड
लोड कैंडिडेट पोर्टफोलियो क्लिक इनेबल
एडिटिंग देखो क्लिक इनेबल एडिटिंग
एंड या फिर क्लिक इनेबल कंटेंट टू अलव द
ग्लोबल बैंक केमएस केएमएस एड्स इन टू
वेरीफाई योर सेशन की
है प्रोफेशनल
एंड चलो इसको भी हम क्या कर देते हैं अभी
के लिए नीचे एंटर कर देते हैं। टाइम
स्टैंप भी हमने ऐड कर दिया। इसमें कोई भी
टाइम स्टैंप रख सकते हो। हमने ये टाइम
स्टैंप भी हमने यहां पर ऐड कर दिया है।
चलो ठीक है तो बिल्कुल ये एक प्रोफेशनल
लुकिंग सिनेरियो दिख रहा है शायद मे बी
परफेक्टली फाइन।
और इसको चाहे तो हम इसको और छोटा नहीं
करेंगे। सही है।
और अगर इसको प्रोफेशनलली ऐड थोड़ा सा अभी
एक काम करते हैं। अभी इसके लिए इसकी
बैकग्राउंड सेट करते हैं। टेबल का
बैकग्राउंड सेट करते हैं। तो टेबल लेआउट
टेबल डिज़ टेल टेबल का बैकग्राउंड हम सेट
करेंगे। कुछ
लाइट स्लेट हम मैंने इसके लिए भी कलर
सोडिंग एक काम करते हैं। बिल्कुल लाइट यह
रहा। इसका बैकग्राउंड रखते हैं
लाइट सेट के लिए या फिर हम इसको मैनुअल कर
दें मोर कलर कस्टम और मैंने इसके लिए एक
वैल्यू लिखी हुई है
क्योंकि आप जितने प्रोफेशनल एडिटर होगे ना
उतना ही वो कर पाओगे
F3
F4
F6
देखो हो गया। परफेक्ट फाइन। अभी मुझे क्या
करना है? ये तो हो गया। अभी मैं क्या करता
हूं? इसके बॉर्डर्स को रिमूव भी करूंगा।
ठीक है? अब चलते हैं हम यहां पर लेआउट पर।
इसके बॉर्डर पर चलते हैं और मुझे सबसे
पहले क्या है? नो बॉर्डर। सारे बॉर्डर हटा
दिए मैंने। अब मैं क्या करता हूं? ओनली ये
वाला बॉर्डर रखता हूं। कौन से वाला? आपका
लेफ्ट बॉर्डर। ओनली लेफ्ट बॉर्डर रखूंगा।
तो लेफ्ट बॉर्डर को मैं सेलेक्ट कर लिया।
उसका मैं पॉइंट का सेक्शन करता हूं। ये
रहा। कुछ रखता हूं इसका पॉइंट थ्री पॉइंट
का रखता हूं मैं अराउंड हां थ्री पॉइंट का
बॉर्डर सेलेक्ट करता हूं। ये रहा हमारा
यहां पर
सेलेक्ट कर लिया। चलो थ्री पॉइंट का आपका
बॉर्डर सेलेक्ट हो गया। उसके बाद इसको मैं
कलर देता हूं। इसका कलर हम सेलेक्ट करते
हैं कुछ इस टाइप से।
एंड ये परफेक्ट यह सही रहेगा या और क्या
करते हैं इसको? और लाइट कलर देते हैं हम।
तो इसका हम कस्टम इसमें भी कलर लिख देते
हैं। कस्टम कलर
2p
और इसको मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पे पेस्ट
कर देता हूं
यार।
ठीक है? ये हो गया। तो आई होप कि ये अभी
अच्छा दिख रहा होगा आपको। ठीक है। अभी कुछ
प्रोफेशनल दिख रहा होगा। दिख रहा है।
ओके अभी दिख रहा है प्रोफेशनल परफेक्ट
और आगे एक काम और कर देते हैं इसको अच्छे
से और एंटर करने के लिए यह रहा ना वेट
कंट्रोल जेड
इसको हम एक काम कर देते हैं
यह हो गया। एंड इसके लिए भी हम क्या करते
हैं? यहां पर एंटर कर देते हैं।
ये रहा परफेक्ट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हो गया। अभी सही दिख रहा है। अभी इसमें
मुझे लगता है कुछ हमें वो करने की जरूरत
नहीं है। और एक्सटर्नल रिक्वायर्ड के बाद
भी हम स्पेस दे देते हैं।
ओके हो गया। तो ये था आपका फर्स्ट पॉइंट
जो जिससे हमें क्या करना है? इनेबल कंटेंट
पे क्या करवाना है? उनसे क्लिक करवाना है।
इनेबल कंटेंट पे हमें उनसे क्लिक करवाना
है। इसको और भी प्रोफेशनल आप बना सकते हो।
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है? जस्ट इसी के
नीचे आपको रिज्यूे लिखना है। जस्ट इसी के
नीचे आपको रियल रिज्यूे लिखना है। तो जस्ट
मैंने क्या किया? टेबल से बाहर आ गया।
यहां पर एंटर किया और यहां पर मैं लिखूंगा
वो रिज्यूे। कहां पर है मेरा रिज्यूुमे?
ये रहा। ये रहा। कैंडिडेट है विक्रमादित्य
राठौड़। किसी का नाम तो नहीं है? यह हमारा
यहां रिज्यूे रहा। तो अभी हम रिज्यूे
बनाते हैं यहां पर।
यहां पर हमने कर दिया पेस्ट। तो भैया चलो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। पेस्ट कर देते हैं।
तो नाउ पहले इसको क्या करते हैं? हम
सेलेक्ट करके सबको सेलेक्ट कर लेते हैं एक
पर्टिकुलर उसमें
एंड एरियल परफेक्ट फाइन 12 कर देते हैं।
चलो अब वन बाय वन इसको भी थोड़ा सा
प्रोफेशनल बढ़ाते हैं। आपका कैंडिडेट ये
हो गया हाईलाइट
विक्रमादित्य राठौड़ इसको भी मैंने क्या
कर दिया? बोल्ड कर दिया। टारगेट रोल है
इसका। यह रहा
टारगेट रोल है। यह इसकी रजिस्ट्रेशन आईडी
यहां पर हमने लिखा
उसके बाद क्लीयरेंस स्टेटस
को है परफेक्टली फाइन और एक काम और कर
देता हूं इस चीज में एक चीज और रहेगी मेरे
पास प्रोफेशनल और बनाने के लिए नॉर्मली ये
रहा और प्रोफेशनल बनाने के लिए ये रहा
ये रहा
इसके लिए इसके बाद एग्जीक्यूटिव समरी पे
आते हैं हम
देन एग्जीक्यूटिव समरी परफेक्टली फाइन
वेरीफाइड बैकग्राउंड चेक हो गया। देन ये
सीनियर लोड जो भी है ना परफेक्ट कोर
कंपटेंसी ये रही क्लाउड ये रहा। इसको हम
क्या करते हैं यहां पर अभी
क्लाउड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एडब्ल्यूएस इस
जबरदस्त इसका प्रोफेशनल बनाते हैं।
बिल्कुल
और इसको भी हम बना देते हैं। यह रहा
भाई क्लास में जो कुछ होगा ना
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल हम बिल्कुल लेजिटमेट
क्लास होगी बिल्कुल लेजिटमेट होगी अदरवाइज
नहीं होती है अपनी क्लासेस लेजिटिमेट ही
रहती है डोंट वरी जो भी है क्लासेस का
अपना यही है कि हम लेंगे तो लेजिटमेट
क्लास लेंगे अदरवाइज नहीं लेते कि
प्रोफेशनल क्लासेस होनी चाहिए जैसे कि
परफेक्ट मजा आया आप लोगों को कि सच में
ऐसा सही होना चाहिए। चलो
अब बताओ मन ही मजा आ रहा तो बताओ आप लोग।
एंड ये रहा आपका प्रोफेशनलली। फिर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां हो गया।
नेक्स्ट
कौन है आपका? ये रहा।
क्योंकि बहुत लोग बोलते हैं कि सर हम इसको
कैसे बनाएंगे और कैसे करेंगे हमें समझ में
नहीं आ रहा तो अभी समझने का टाइम है यह
ठीक है अभी यही आपके समझने का टाइम है कि
हम कैसे इसको प्रोफाइल बना सकते हैं और
कैसे हम इसको यूज़ भी कर सकते हैं। देखो
तो यह रहा आपको कुछ परफेक्ट
चलो
नेक्स्ट हो गया ये हो गया चलो मेरे ख्याल
से अभी इसमें कहीं पर कुछ भी कमी नहीं दिख
रही हमें किसी को दिख रही है कोई कमी
नहीं दिख रही है ना और इसको हम एक काम कर
देते हैं ये रहा इसको सेलेक्ट करते हैं और
सेलेक्ट करने के बाद हमने क्या कर दिया
इसको ये कर दिया तो और भी प्रोफेशनल हो
गया।
जो हम कर सकते हैं मैक्सिमम क्या करेंगे।
चलो
बन गया क्या? रेजोमे भी हमने बना लिया।
ओके जूम के बाद हमें क्या करना है अभी
इसको
अभी आपको क्या करना है यह जो यह वाला सारा
टेक्स्ट ये रहा आपका विक्रम राड वाला पूरा
टेक्स्ट आपको क्या करना है सेलेक्ट करना
है इसको सेलेक्ट करना है ये यहां तक हो
गया सेलेक्ट आपका सेलेक्ट करने के बाद
आपको क्या करना है यहां पर राइट क्लिक
करना है राइट क्लिक करने के बाद यहां पर
एक ऑप्शन आ रहा है फोंट का ठीक है राइट
क्लिक करने के बाद आपको आ रहा है एक ऑप्शन
फोंट का तो यहां पर क्लिक किया फोंट पे
आपको जाना है फोंट पे जाने के बाद आपको
क्या करना है। उसके बाद आपको क्या करना
है? इफेक्ट के ऊपर जाना है। वेदा एडवांस
में जाना है। वेदा भेजा योर योर योर योर
योर इफेक्ट्स यहां पर इफेक्ट दिखा रहे हैं
आपको और यहां पर हिडन है। ये लिखा ना हिडन
आपको इसके ऊपर क्या करना है? क्लिक करना
है। हिडन के ऊपर क्लिक करना है। समझ में आ
गया? आपको ओनली मैं आपको फिर से बता देता
हूं। मैं इसको एक बार कैंसिल कर देता हूं।
देखो आपको जो टेबल बनाई थी ना हमने ये
टेबल ये वाले टेबल को छोड़कर इसके नीचे ये
जो पूरा रिज्यूे है इसको सेलेक्ट करना है।
सेलेक्ट करने के बाद राइट क्लिक करना है।
राइट क्लिक करने के बाद फों्ट पे जाना है।
फों्ट पे जाने के बाद आपको जो इफेक्ट्स है
इफेक्ट के अंदर हिडन पर क्लिक करना है और
ओके कर देना है। ये हो गया हाइड। ये हो
गया आपका हाइड। ठीक है? अभी आपको ये दिखाई
दे रहा है? नहीं दिखाई दे रहा। अभी आपको
ये दिखाई नहीं दे रहा। ओके? यह हमारा
प्रोफेशनल अभी आपको सिर्फ यही दिखाई देगा
जो अभी आपको स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे रहा है
ना आपको यही दिखने वाला है किसके अंदर
जब आप उसको ओपन करोगे जब आप इसको ओपन
करोगे यही दिखने वाला है ओनली स्क्रीन के
ऊपर और उसके बाद इनेबल कंटेंट होगा तभी वो
दिखेगा वो कैसे दिखेगा उसकी भी हम
प्रोग्रामिंग करेंगे तो इसको अभी आपको
क्या करना है फाइल पर जाना है सेव एज पे
जाना है और डॉक्यूमेंट का नाम रखना है अब
डॉक्यूमेंट का नाम रखते हैं हम